ici c'était c'était une piste de danse
on est en train de tout démonter
présentement
mariage baptême artiste invité le
restaurant Les Nuits de Beyrouth
accueillait jusqu'à 700 personnes par
soir
aujourd'hui on vide ce grand local ça
représente ma vie toutes mes économies
je les ai mis là-dedans un sentiment
d'impuissance habite monadyb elle et ses
associés affirment avoir tenu tête au
crime organisé en refusant des demandes
d'extorsion en un an le restaurant a été
victime de 4 incendies criminels ce qui
a mis fin à la couverture d'assurance
incapable d'en trouver une autre
convenant aux demandes du locataire les
propriétaires mettent la clé sous la
porte aujourd'hui c'est eux demain ça va
être qui pourquoi eux qui sont des
victimes doivent vivre cette situation
là pourquoi il y a pas de loi pour les
protéger moi c'est ça qui me frustre
en moins d'un an plus de 60 événements
violents ont touché les commerçants de
la communauté arabe de Laval et Montréal
ces joueurs là sont souvent des membres
du crime organisé libanais l'extorsion
va aller de la façon suivante on les
approche et on leur dit de donner un
montant mensuel pour éviter des
problèmes et ces montants là s'ils ne
sont pas remis et bien à ce moment-là
c'est des menaces qui vont pas escalade
cette année le SPVM note une
augmentation des incendies criminels par
rapport aux années précédentes les
personnes qui mettent leur feu
évidemment ce ne sont pas les personnes
qui sont à la feuille de ces groupes
criminalisés donc ils vont se faire
offrir de la drogue ils vont se faire
offrir un montant d'argent pour aller
commettre l'incendie
en mars dernier la Sûreté du Québec le
Service de police de Montréal et de
Laval affirmait s'attaquer au crime
organisé du Moyen-Orient avec le projet
mèche menant à une vingtaine
d'arrestations mais entre temps des
commerçants épuisés jettent l'éponge ici
marie-abelle Rochon Radio-Canada Laval